In the TV show "Ted Lasso,"
this 26,000-seat stadium
is filled to the brim.
But this shot --
it was created during
the COVID-19 pandemic.
Now, pause and zoom in here.
See this woman? She's not really here.
In fact, she was shot on a
completely different continent.
And this shot?
The majority of these
people aren't even real.
The "Ted Lasso" team pushed the boundaries
on how they could safely
fill out the stands.
And knowing all the different
ways these crowds were made
could change the way we see large crowds
in movies and TV forever.
The largest crowd scene ever shot
was for the movie "Gandhi,"
which holds the Guinness World Record
for most film extras,
with this funeral procession,
reportedly made up of
300,000 real marchers.
But directing this many
extras is expensive,
not to mention a huge
logistical challenge.
So movies have turned
to using fake people,
like this painted matte
backdrop in 1959's "Ben-Hur"
or these inflatable extras
in 2006's "Glory Road,"
which are an easy way to
give more real-life depth
to a fake crowd in the distance.
But fake crowds also come
with their own limitations.
They can save the crew money
and properly fill an arena,
but they can't move or
interact on their own
like real people.
So the "Ted Lasso" team decided to use
a combination of real and fake people
to make their crowds look
as realistic as possible.
Barnstorm VFX had two big
problems to deal with.
First, because of the pandemic,
they couldn't fill the stands with
as many real people as
they normally would.
Plus, they weren't permitted to film
on the field at the real
Selhurst Park Stadium,
which the fictional Nelson
Road Stadium is based on.
So, how did they get all these people
to fill 26,000 seats?
They constructed an entire CG stadium
and used a technique called plate extras.
Filming real people the crew can direct
is best for capturing
distinct gestures up close,
like this moment in "Ted Lasso"
where the fans lift their fingers
and shout a very specific
curse word at Ted.
Crowd: Wanker!
Coach Beard: Let's give it a shot.
Narrator: Plate extras are filmed
in front of a green screen
and then digitally scattered
into the desired shots.
The extras are filmed
in an array of costumes
while doing a wide range of movements.
Lawson Deming: Oftentimes a set of actions
that sort of flows into one another,
like cheers that flow into a boo,
standing up, sitting down.
Narrator: A typical
plate shoot might involve
well over 100 extras,
but because of lockdown rules,
Barnstorm could only use around 20 people,
members of its own team in Los Angeles.
But social distancing
didn't hurt the production.
Plate extras aren't filmed
next to each other normally,
but further apart than they
would be in a real crowd.
That way, they can be placed
more easily in the final shot.
These plate extras were also
filmed from multiple angles.
Deming: We shot head-on, front 45,
and then a full profile angle,
because we knew that we weren't gonna
see people from behind.
Narrator: In this scene,
the majority of extras
from this angle were actually on set,
but this guy here?
Another extra who was shot separately,
because, according to Deming,
the production team didn't like
these two empty seats here.
So we did, like, the
smallest crowd addition
we've ever done. It was a high angle,
so we couldn't just shoot someone head-on,
on a green screen.
I had to estimate the angle and say,
oh, what lens do we
think this was shot on?
What do we think the camera height was?
Get up on a ladder, shoot down,
look at the shot, compare it.
Narrator: Still, Deming couldn't shoot
as many plate extras as he had hoped,
so they only made up a
small portion of the crowd.
And substituting in green-screened people
is never as good as having people on set.
So when that's possible,
a production might choose a
technique called crowd tiling.
Basically, the crew shoots one small group
and physically moves them around the set.
They're then combined
together in postproduction.
This is how the "Ted Lasso" crew created
part of the backdrop behind Jamie here.
You can also see an
example of this technique
in "Insecure," where Issa and her friends
go to a concert in season
three, episode five.
Take a look at this overhead shot
of hundreds of concertgoers.
In reality, there was a group
of fewer than 200 extras on the field.
In five separate shots,
that group was placed in the left, right,
center, and back of the venue
and rotoscoped together into one shot.
Crowd tiling is key if you're
dealing with varied lighting.
As you can see in the finished shot,
the crowds in the front,
the middle, and the back
are all being hit with
different color lights.
And a lot of work has to be
done to hide the duplication.
Deming: Your eye is very
good at catching duplication.
When you're not careful about
how you do crowd tiling,
you can literally end up with
the same people next to themselves.
Narrator: These tiles
that formed this one shot
from "Insecure" took an hour
and a half total to shoot
and end up on screen for only one second.
And this technique really only works
when you have stationary shots.
Deming: You only have that one angle.
You can't move the camera during it.
It literally just works for
the one angle that you shot it from.
Narrator: For "Ted
Lasso," the limited amount
of real extras, both on set
and in front of a green screen,
left the crew with few
head-on shots for tiling.
So how did they manage to get the stands
to look so full in shots like this?
Digital doubles -- a method
that's less realistic up close
but can be used to fill
in gaps from a distance.
Digital doubles made up an estimated 90%
of the show's crowd shots.
The less detailed doubles
came from a template,
but productions can
create more detailed ones
by scanning real actors,
like Margot Robbie in "I, Tonya."
This technique is the most
versatile of them all.
Doubles can be relit
and shot from any angle.
Plus, you can make more unique characters.
Deming knew the "Ted Lasso" games
were largely shot in the evening.
This meant dressing the
doubles for cold weather
in CG scarfs, hats, and jackets.
Because they're completely CGI characters,
we can control everything
about their appearance.
Narrator: Unlike matte extras
and inflatable dummies,
you can also make digital doubles move
and react to the action in the scene.
In "Ted Lasso," different
sections of the crowd
sometimes needed to have
two reactions at once,
since two teams would
be playing each other.
So they used a crowd-simulator
software called Golaem.
Here, the software is identifying 90%
of the available seats in
this section of the stadium,
filling it with angry front-facing fans
dressed in the home team's colors.
The same programming that allows us
to assign them a particular
color shirt, for example,
also allows us to assign
them a particular reaction.
Narrator: During this shot,
where AFC Richmond scores a goal,
any digital double wearing
the red and blue of that team
was programmed to cheer.
Deming: Because we have this control,
the entire crowd simulation
essentially knows.
We can categorize them
as being on this side.
Narrator: It still needs to feel
like a real human movement,
as opposed to a faked movement.
So Barnstorm's animators
donned motion-capture suits
and fed every movement to the software.
And the hardest action? Clapping.
Two CG hands going in for a clap
will naturally want to
intersect with one another,
and the suit alone couldn't
capture everything.
Deming: Oftentimes you'll
end up in this situation
where, just imagine trying to clap
without moving your wrists
and without moving your fingers.
You end up with people
doing this sort of like,
a seal, you know,
like the seal clapping for their food.
Narrator: So the animators also wore
separate mo-cap gloves,
a relatively recent
innovation in the industry,
to perfect the complex hand movements.
The key to faking a realistic crowd
like they did in "Ted Lasso"
is to combine these techniques
into a cohesive whole.
Deming: I think my preferred
method of creating a crowd
is anything that works.
You're not restricting
yourself to one method,
so the audience is never
gonna quite catch on,
even if they think they
know what you're doing.
Animator: Oh, my God! That's
a soccer ball in a goal!
I'm so fricking excited!
Yes!